we have
dylan leclair joining us now live how
are you buddy doing good uh i like the
the past segment about the the dow hack
that's interesting what do you think
about it
can you guys stop trading um
yeah i mean
it's i think everybody should go uh at
least read about it learn about it uh
it's a you know it's important part of
you know crypto history uh and it you
know i think there's a lot of lessons
there uh so it's it's interesting to see
kind of the
you know the trans the transparency of
these blockchains and the hacks and all
that happens and you know the narrative
that bitcoin crypto is for criminals uh
when a lot of this stuff happens
completely transparent and law
enforcement cracks down and it seems a
little bit uh you know counterintuitive
a lot of narratives so uh you know
that's i guess my like basic thoughts
yeah when you think about uh
kind of the chain splits the hard forks
you know obviously the uh your reference
there to uh i think it's vitalik uh
saying like hey can you guys stop
trading um obviously there's things like
you know developers do something over
over the history of uh bitcoin
cryptocurrencies that has uh become kind
of funny uh memes uh wha what's your
general sense of like the bitcoin
perspective on like never changing uh
and kind of remaining rigid and whatever
happens happens but the chain stays the
chain versus some of these other
approaches like around the dow hack and
the hard fork like do you think that
it's important uh that bitcoin has
stayed rigid or are there times where it
would have been beneficial to have
actually pursued a summer strategy
yeah i mean i think that's just the
difference between bitcoin and a lot of
the the crypto ecosystem and that's okay
you know bitcoin has just this immutable
uh chain of property rights and you know
it's gonna tick-tock next block you
can't do anything about it a block will
be mined you know in the next 10 minutes
or whenever it does and no one in
anywhere in the world can do anything to
stop that um whereas like you know with
ethereum or solana like you know there's
there's times where the chain stops all
together because they need to fix
something that's okay i just it's just
you know that when you're talking about
money uh global set like decentralized
money for the world to use versus you
know a smart contracts chain or platform
uh you know there's obviously a lot of
differences there and that's okay i mean
that's that's where the debate comes in
but when you try to compare the two or
claim something is ultrasound money or
uh you know that they're even competing
at all um even though you know because
of the crypto market liquidity a lot of
times when bitcoins up a lot of altcoins
chains are also the ticker symbol is up
or when bitcoin's down the whole
market's down i think it's just you know
the conversation or the debate i guess
if you want to call it uh should just be
shifted entirely because they're not
really competing for the same market
despite what a lot of people think
yeah i think that's a very uh very fair
way to look at it uh let's get into uh
some of the charts that uh that you've
got for us today uh you've got the usdc
and usdt circulating supplies so uh this
is circles uh stablecoin and then tether
uh the numbers just keep going up and to
the right man it's pretty impressive to
see how fast this stuff's growing why is
this important
yeah so the past couple weeks we talked
about you know equity market
correlations we looked at on-chain stuff
we looked at derivative stuff
so today i thought i'd just throw
together some stuff about kind of the
stablecoin market and and how that's
blossoming um just to cover something a
little bit different but you know an
important part of this entire ecosystem
so uh you know circle tether uh the two
leading stablecoin issuers we see
rumblings of
uh cbdc talks whether that's congress or
the uh you know fed governor saying hey
we need a central bank digital currency
we're seeing what's happening in canada
with that you know aggressive overreach
by government on people's uh bank
accounts and financial services so all
this stuff is going to be uh you know
heavily debated over the coming years
and so um you know do you want to hold
something like a stable coin that can be
you know uh like choke point by uh some
some central issue or i think a lot of
people are gonna come to realize that
their money isn't actually their money
so stable coins um they're actually
serving a pretty big purpose in in the
world in like in this ecosystem and no
it's not uh immutable decentralized
money like say bitcoin is that's
censorship resistant seizure resistant
but what it does do is it allows dollars
to kind of flow freely on crypto rails
so this next chart the circulating
supply here is about 120 billion year
over year uh the growth is like 200
percent it was about four it was about
40 billion dollars combined uh a year
ago today and so
um over the last year these two uh
stable coins have done like two trillion
dollars of transfer volume each which is
like you know
like an order of magnitude a couple
orders of magnitude more than their
actual market cap so that they're
actually like the the
circulation rate or how fast these
things are changing hands is actually
remarkable uh when you're thinking about
this versus say dollars in the banking
system
and so you know for the longest time the
crypto market didn't even have any
stable coins it's just like bitcoin was
your was your kind of your safe haven
and when the when these kind of local
bubbles pop you had nowhere to really
run and the on and off ramps are really
really tricky to use um so now people
you can debate you know how safe
uh some stable coins are or if their
reserves are backed or not and that's an
entirely different discussion
but a lot of these stable coins and i
think you know increasingly so will just
hold treasuries and essentially they're
just like
you know us dollars treasuries that can
be changed hands in crypto markets in
you know a couple seconds around the
world and so uh in terms of innovation
uh i don't know i don't know how it's
just you know another kind of database
entry on a honest you know centralized
ledger and that's fine but it's a lot
better than you know say the the legacy
banking system and integration with the
crypto markets today so when you look at
uh the stable coin like uh we looked at
both the circulating supply and the
annual transfer volume uh is it your
thought process that just more and more
the financial system is going to move
over because these are superior rails to
other dollar rails uh and people who
want that stable value as long as they
can get comfortable with any perceived
or real risks of what's backing it
auditing it etc once they get
comfortable with that just the entire
financial system will flow over into
stables
yeah so i mean how i think about it is
and and i focus on on bitcoin you know
with almost all my time because i think
it fixes or addresses one of the biggest
problems in the world today there's a
300 400 trillion dollar problem and
we've talked about that it's a broken
cost of capital right so if you have
money in the bank account you deposit
with a bank they actually lend your
money out for you fractionally they
fractionally reserve your deposit and
lend it out to other
debtors
but you don't get any of that yield you
don't get any of that upside even though
uh they're lending it out on your behalf
um so so that zero percent yield you get
in a seven percent inflationary
environment uh you know you're not doing
too well but with say stable coins are
in this kind of
emerging crypto bitcoin ecosystem what
you can do is you can actually lend
peer-to-peer so say on ftx a centralized
you know
exchange you can lend your dollars to
someone else that's using margin or you
know let's say a d5 protocol right
you're putting you're putting stable
coins into a liquidity pool and right
there's there's a debate about you know
what's the custodial risk what's the uh
the platform risk on a lot of these
protocols
is you know are they going to get hacked
are there exploits and that's something
that people are finding out in real time
like it's not risk-free in the sense
that you know nobody there's not the
fdic gonna back you if you get hacked
right but what you can do is you can
lend your stables out or you can borrow
dollars
at a really a market rate right so
sometimes that market rate in this
ecosystem is five percent sometimes it's
20 but these markets are free and open
and these stable coins allow basically
you know creditors debtors people that
want to collateralize their assets and
borrow or
lend to someone else to do that at a
rate that's decided by the market and
not 12 guys sitting in a room saying the
fed's fund rate is going to be zero
percent again and so i think that's the
exciting thing about what's happening
with you know kind of dollars on crypto
rails yeah it's wild that there's 12
people who make that decision but that
is the world that we live in today uh
you've got this chart on stable coin
supply ratio explain what uh what you're
looking at here
yeah so this is just over the last
couple years as stable coins have become
a bigger and bigger part of the market
this is
uh the stable coin supply ratio is
basically the bitcoin market cap uh
divided by the stable coin market cap so
right now i just included usdt and usdc
because they're the two biggest but
there's other uh stable coins out there
there's some kind of um you know
algorithmic stable coins so like they're
collateralized with other assets and
they're not actually backed by dollars
in a bank account there's all sorts of
things but basically this is the
aggregate stable coin market cap as a
percentage of the bitcoin market cap and
what you can see is with this ratio
falling uh you know the buying power of
these of this dry powder in the market
relative to the bitcoin market continues
to get larger and larger and so um i
have these kind of bollinger bands on
this on the supply ratio and and when it
gets to the upper band
it's basically that the bitcoin market
cap is is really big compared to the
size of like the dry powder on the
sidelines stable coins and when it hits
that kind of lower threshold it's
showing the opposite it's saying that
that dry powder is a pretty significant
portion of this this bitcoin market cap
and so we're on one of those lower bands
uh all that's showing and we're honestly
at like a near historic low in this
supply ratio so it's showing that the
stable coin dry powder on the sidelines
you know 120 billion plus uh relative to
the bitcoin market cap
is is pretty substantial and so there's
you know there's a lot of people on the
sidelines uh waiting to buy the dip
yeah that's uh that's probably uh gonna
be a good decision if we look at the
historical uh uh perspective what
usually plays out uh you've got bitcoin
futures open interest uh why is this
important
yeah so this is uh the stablecoin margin
uh open interest right so with bitcoin
futures um you're basically you're
entering a contract and that contract's
marked to market every second um and you
can enter that contract with various
sorts of collateral and traditionally uh
when these derivative markets first were
spun up you were actually collateralized
if you were long bitcoin you were
collateralizing that contract with
bitcoin or with another crypto asset but
mainly bitcoin i mean you know i guess
sometimes it you know you can do it with
eth but traditionally it's bitcoin as a
as collateral in these markets and so
now increasingly so what you're seeing
is stable coins um as as basically
collateral in these derivative markets
are becoming more and more prevalent and
so that that actually is is pretty good
in terms of risk profile for bulls uh
because when there's these downturns
these these big market crashes uh and
your long bitcoin with bitcoin as
collateral it gets pretty ugly and that
that unwind is somewhat reflexive your
collateral is going down in value your
profit your p l is going down and so it
basically forces people to sell you know
it's these cascading liquidations that
you see and so stable coins uh as
collateral and kind of entering these
derivative markets really uh is it
advantageous for for uh these traders
and i think that's why you're seeing it
become more and more prevalent uh over
the last couple years
all right and then when we look at
bitcoin percent futures open interest
crypto margin this is kind of another
variation of a similar thing
yeah so this is just uh the percentage
of that so with this with this chart
declining over time right now about 42
percent of the market is is crypto
margin so if you can think of the
inverse 58
of this market is is the futures open
interest in bitcoin uh which is you know
a 10 billion dollar plus market uh is
and i and on the futures open interest i
quoted it in bitcoin terms so it kind of
you know does like it uh evens out that
volatility but 58 is stable coin margin
and compared to say 30 at the top of the
market so in the top in april you had
basically 70 of the derivatives market
they were taking their bitcoin they're
long in bitcoin with bitcoin as
collateral right so that's obviously not
very sustainable and we're seeing you
know that trend actually uh reverse big
time and so much more healthy state of
the derivatives market and uh you know i
expect that trend
to continue into the future got it and
then when you look at this three-month
annualized rolling basis of bitcoin
futures what are you seeing there seems
just kind of have been just going down
since about november
yeah so we talked about this uh one of
our episodes uh the podcast episodes we
did where we talked about bitcoin as a
solution to the broken cost of capital
and we talked about you know how
bitcoin's a sparing asset but the
markets around bitcoin uh kind of are
entrenching themselves as this new form
of like almost risk-free cost of capital
so this futures uh rolling basis what
you can do is you can sell futures and
you can long the spot and oftentimes
almost all the time the future is the
front one month or three month futures
is trading ahead of that spot market
price and so right now with this metric
at about five percent you can capture
about a five percent annualized yield by
just selling the three month forward
futures long spot and and your market
neutral but you're collecting that yield
and so uh during times where the markets
you know very speculative bulls are very
speculative say in november of 2021 it
was this was about at 20 so you could
capture 20 annualized steal at the top
of the market in in about april you
could get about a 45 uh annualized
return and so this just kind of shows
that speculative nature of the market
but increasingly you see institutions
coming in
that really are market neutral they're
taking no upside or downside risk in
bitcoin but they're collecting this this
you know this annualized return and so
this kind of basis this risk-free yield
if you want to call it it's it's all
throughout the crypto bitcoin ecosystem
whether it's futures whether it's
perpetual futures whether it's d5
protocols or yields uh basically this
there's kind of this new uh you know
cost of capital uh that that's uh
completely like contrary to the the wall
street wealth garden legacy system where
you know junk bonds are yielding you
five percent before inflation before
default risk uh you know it's it's
almost like there's this new parallel
system where people are saying nope this
is actually the real cost of capital and
i'm not parting with my money for for a
negative yield
john what questions you got dylan how do
you think about the different stable
coins and evaluating them so if you want
to put money into the stable coin market
and kind of collect those yields that a
lot of companies offer what do you
choose between like usdc usdt
gemini usd like how do you think about
that
yeah so i mean i think you know a lot of
a lot of the tethered truthers have been
not proven wrong but there's definitely
some questionable things in the past
about whether they are fully backed and
the things that biffonex and tether did
and there's a whole kind of rabbit hole
you can go down with that about where
they fully back throughout time but
i think you know the reason audits look
good but i think the biggest thing is um
i would say probably usdc is the
strongest uh in terms of like you know
the regulatory environment and and
having a proof of reserves but uh you
know if you are say a tether truther and
say that tether is fraud
if you really believe that well there's
a simple thing you can do you can simply
go into the market you can short you can
borrow tether and you can you can buy
uscc you can buy bitcoin you can buy any
asset and if if tether turns out to be
fraud we'll congrats you shorted it so
like you know i think a lot of it is
more so talk when in reality if you have
the strong thesis if you really believe
that uh you know some of these stable
coins are fraudulent or not well you
know go out and short it because there's
you know there's huge markets with
billions of dollars to do this very
thing
dylan when you start to look at uh a lot
of what's going on in canada obviously
the russia ukraine stuff i've seen the
number of headlines that are like oh
people are selling their bitcoin because
russia's going to invade ukraine or oh
people are buying bitcoin because of
what's happening in canada uh one
like how do you evaluate uh what if that
is true and what is not and also two is
do you think that the geopolitical uh
movements globally have uh that much
impact on bitcoin buying and selling
market price etc
yeah so i mean i think the the canadian
kind of uh thing is uh somewhat not
unprecedented but if you would have said
a liberal democracy first world country
you know our our friendly neighbors up
north uh would kind of
turn to author authoritarianism rather
quickly uh where you know anyone that is
peacefully opposing uh the kind of
political party in power would have
their bank accounts frozen assets
potentially seized you know credit cards
turned off uh you know i don't think a
lot of people expected that so whereas
bitcoin was kind of this digital gold
narrative speculative asset now it's
okay wait the the theories about
censorship resistance uh and you know
being your own bank it's not more it's
not a theory anymore it's like you know
it's happening in practice and we need
we need money that can't be that can't
be arbitrarily taken from us and so i
think a lot of people are waking up and
saying i my money's not safe in the bank
uh you know and they just you know
people average people that donated their
money to peaceful protesters this is not
like you know this isn't like they're a
radical extremist at all i mean have you
seen the videos they're just leaving
flags and jumping around in bouncy
houses it's like rather peaceful and so
i think a lot of people are waking up to
what's happening up north in terms of
you know the geopolitical ins
instability uh i put out kind of a joke
tweet yesterday about you know my thread
about my uh my observations on ukraine
and russia and then said like i'm no
expert i have nothing to offer here um
i'll leave that to other people but uh
you know a lot of people are trading
this and if you're looking at bitcoin
inequities trading tick for tick over
the last couple weeks
i think more so that's what's happening
is that uh the the implications of
what's happening in terms of currency
markets bonds equities um there's ripple
effects into the bitcoin markets and so
you know if people are buying or selling
bitcoin because of what putin said in
the speech or not i think that's more
short-term noise and you know the bull
case for for bitcoin and and why we need
it in the world today uh is never been
stronger and i think that's clear for
anybody that's kind of paying attention
to what's happening yeah it makes a lot
of sense the other piece too that seems
to uh uh be interesting development is
we're seeing more and more politicians
start to get into bitcoin stable coins
uh crypto conversation in general now
we've seen everything from politicians
put forward uh legislative ideas around
uh hey you will not be able to create a
central bank digital currency that
doesn't meet these criteria that
basically preserve the benefits of cash
there's people who have put forward at
the state level uh legal tender uh
legislation uh for bitcoin like how do
you think about politicians and their
participation in some of this stuff now
uh is it just a foregone conclusion that
they're all gonna have to get on board
or can some of them still fight it
yeah i mean the overturn the overton
window is shifting uh rapidly right uh
where you know it was kind of this niche
thing uh to support bitcoin crypto a
couple years back and now it seems like
it's totally shifting to where if you
don't support this openly uh you're not
going to stand a chance and so you know
the midterms are going to be really
exciting we talked about it i think a
month or two back about you know how
this incentive has changed pretty
rapidly um so i think that's going to be
a kind of a trend this midterms and
especially uh in the 2024 you know uh
presidential elections uh a lot of
stuff's going to be happening it's
pretty exciting and i think uh
incentives align and this isn't just a
u.s thing uh this isn't just a state
level thing this is a kind of a game
theory that's playing out everywhere in
the world right where we see ukele and
el salvador uh they're just the first
dominoes so we're gonna see a lot of
exciting things happen that i think
you're gonna catch a lot of people by
surprise over the coming years
got it before we let you go real quick
how are we looking on followers
uh
not not too not too much growth here i
think not too much growth what's going
on
you've been doing reds or what yeah is
the tweeter machine
oh you're at 125. you're uh you've not
hit like a nice round number there
yeah not too bad i'll pick up the pick
up the tweeting this this this week he's
taking a little bit of a break yeah just
like just you know there's a couple
strategies you can employ on twitter you
can basically uh say smart things you
can say dumb things or you can say hot
takes and sometimes you could wrap all
three of them in the same thread and
don i saw you were getting ragged on for
your podcast take the other day yeah
what was your podcast i said to replace
music with podcasts uh oh like pete like
not i think people took that i think
people took that out of context i meant
like on a road trip like at the gym like
did you say it no
that's how twitter works is how you get
engagement ah that's fine
speaking of uh music uh kanye still has
not dropped his album today people are
pissed they bought a 230 dollar piece of
hardware that looks like he put it
together in his garage uh i love kanye
but uh people are pissed and uh
i'll be at the concert tonight yeah
is it a concert
launch party viewership i think about
this
he's about to fill loon depot park and
people don't even know what they're
going for
they're like as a 50 50 shot kanye shows
up 50 50 shot we listen to new music
5050 shot we listen to him just yelling
to a microphone about topics that's what
i said but i'll be there he may not even
show up
yeah didn't he not show up to one of
them last time
hey whatever watch the documentary he uh
he can do whatever he wants he's good in
my book uh all right dylan thank you so
much for uh for joining us we'll do this
again next tuesday
all right guys